some other fun news for you grab
yourself a mug of beer because today
is national beer day oh yeah and we've
got jacy fernandez at the craft house
brewery for us with some ways to
celebrate
yes cheers you guys it's national beer
day and we are celebrating here's a
little
fact first off when it comes to the
world's favorite beverages number one
is water number two is tea and number
three is beer so let's celebrate
this is wendy she's with the craft house
brewery thank you for having us let's
talk about some of the beers that you
guys have
here at your location absolutely so the
first one here in our tasting flight
that is itron so that's a gozo which
means it's sour so it's going to be a
little bit puckery
and with lemon peel in there a sour beer
so this is going to give me the kind of
sour face when i taste
it i hope not oh i like that
thank you let's taste it right beer
number two beer number two
is also a sour but it's an imperial sour
and it's based off of
a fruit and compo uh puree
parfait with sour yogurt granola and
then we use
three different uh fruit purees in there
acai blueberry and strawberry puree
this sounds like a very healthy beer
sure sure go for it they're all healthy
and then this last one looks very dark
what's this beer here so that is belle
guard that's our cold brew coffee stout
that we uh partner with our neighbor at
vesta coffee and this is actually
caffeine in this beer yes oh this little
pig meal for this afternoon now people
are watching right now they want to come
down after work what are some of the
specials that you have
so for uh national craft beer day we're
doing buy one get one fifty percent off
of the growlers
and also buy one get one fifty percent
off of the crowlers as well okay let's
show them what they did
what these things are because we have
them right here so what's the difference
between the two
sure so a growler is a glass and 64
ounces so that's going to give you four
pints
we fill to order and then the cap goes
on right and then the cool thing about
the crawler is we get to use toys
all right yes so you fill this to order
and then what we do is we put the check
that this is so cool go ahead you have
this
seal and we put it up we're going to
turn it on
and then we're going to seal it to order
i got to send it back to the studio but
this is this is awesome because you can
come down here get your beer to go and
since the aluminum can
it's not going to spill nope and you can
travel with it and actually the
carbonation lasts a lot longer
awesome wendy thank you so much we'll be
back later on in the hour to show you
how to
pour the perfect beer for now we'll send
it back to you guys in the studio
all right thank you jc